cubs have won three straight they sit at
29 and 20. and a very comfortable
five-game lead over saint louis in the
nl central the cubs are the only team
over
500 in the nationally central division
indians are six games back to the white
sox three games back in minnesota they
currently sit third place in the al
central now the 3-1 pitch to lindor
and it's down and in and a lead off walk
one down first standing no score jose
ramirez will bat right-handed
and there's a ground ball single in the
right field cover
quick stop sign uh-huh and lindor will
hold last night they threw him out at
home plate so they've got a little
something going here first and third
nobody is struggling more than this man
the dh from mia reyes and the dirk gets
away here comes wind door flipped the
home and he is safe
great indians take a one-nothing lead on
the wild pitch as lindore got a good
read and immediately dashed for home
savali uh you know in his last four
starts since his last win that complete
game win at pittsburgh he's on three
with a 525 he's got to get off to a
better start in the first three innings
where his era is 5.33
goes the other way
oscar mercado makes the running catch
for out number one rizzo at first two
down contreras the batter and the 2-2
swing and a high fly ball
to fairly shallow left center the left
fielder oscar mercado puts it away and a
good first inning for aaron savalli
charms have been scuffling man two out
of his last 34. as he draws another one
you can still help your team when you're
not
hitting that's an 02 base hit schwarber
is going to try for third and he's going
to make it nice to second
is out so infield in was schwarber third
and hayward
shallow center and it's going to drop
for a hit a broken back
game-tying rbi single
two balls and no strikes on lindor pitch
on the way lined toward left field on
the run maven diving backhand catch
great play by cameron maben the left
fielder
a belly flopping dive moving toward the
line great backhanded catch by the cub
left fielder cameron maben
high fly ball maven back on the warning
track and ramirez just
got under one
top of the order and ian hamp banning
left-handed savali's pitch swung on and
yanked to right base it near the line
and ian happ swinging the bat very well
in this series here is chris bryant the
pitch a swing and a smash up the middle
caught by savali lobs to first to double
up the in half nothing hap could do
about that line drive back to the
pitcher and somali turns it in to the
second double play in his many innings
one out in the man at first batter is
jordan luplow
line tobias throw the first
out they got him
[Applause]
with a great play out at shortstop as he
snagged that line drive by luplow and
then fired a bullet to first base to
double off reyes hayward draws a walk
that puts runners on the corners for
cameron mabin
on a bounce lindor can't get it out of
his glove safe and second cubs grab the
lead
oscar
bounce to third his first time up
mercado blast off deep left field headed
for the bleachers
goodbye and the indians
get one back and tie it up at two see
how much that wind blocked that one the
wind blowing in from left tonight but
mercado hit it well
and he got it on out of here for his
first home run of the season
what do we got here they're pull they're
pulling the players off the field
what happened did we lose a light
oh there's a drone over the top of the
ballpark
is bauer there
arch what tell the people what happens
in 2020
no rules just gonna hold the deal let's
go people
somebody take it down there goes
something you had your chance you blew
it some 16 year old kid is sitting in
his mom's basement
james karen check with two on second and
third nobody out full count now on half
karen shanks pitch fastball got him
swinging
here's chris bryant oh for two hit by a
pitch and bryant swings and misses at a
curveball in the dirt what a pick by
hedges oh like a hockey goalie just an
incredible save by austin hedges
and bryant chased a curveball that may
have hit home plate so the intentional
walk the bases are loaded for the
cleanup hitter wilson contreras he's
ready he delivers and it's swung on a
little jam job headed to short lindor
gloves throws to first and they get him
and karen jack worked out of it how
about that ball game tied at two bottom
of the tenth inning
here's the pitch to bryant swinging a
ground ball base hit left center field
happ started to go back to second and
advances only to third
half goes to third and holds on bryant a
single on the first pitch so the
intentional walk has loaded the bases
for the cubs song on him missy struck
him out
so contreras strikes out with the bases
loaded for the first down in the 10th
inning one down for kyle schwarber swing
and a miss got him with a fastball
base is still loaded now two down
and javi baez the hitter and the o2
pitch by his lines one base hit cubs win
down the left field line
a breaking ball he waited back just long
enough and lined it over the head of
ramirez the cubs win the ball game